so could we talk about fermat's library
yeah absolutely what is it what's the
main goal
what's the dream it is a platform for
annotating papers in its essence
all right and so academic papers can be
one of the densest
forms of content out there and and
generally
pretty hard to understand at times and
the idea is that you can make them more
accessible and easier to understand by
adding these
rich annotations to the side right and
so we can just imagine
a pdf view on your browser and then you
have annotations on each side and then
when you click on them
a sidebar expands and then you have
annotations that support latex and
markdown
and so the idea is that you can say
explain a tougher part of a paper
where there's a step that is not
completely obvious
or you can add more context to it and
then over time papers can
become easier and and easier to
understand and can evolve in a way
but it really came from myself louise
and two other friends we've been
we've had this this long-running habit
of kind of running a journal club
amongst us we come from different
backgrounds right i studied cs
we studied physics and so we'd read
papers and present them
to each other and uh and then we tried
to
bring some of that online and that's
that's
that's when we decided to to to build
vermont's library
um then over time it kind of grew into
into something uh with with a broader
goal uh and really what we're trying to
do
is trying to help uh move science in the
in the the right direction
that's really the ultimate goal and and
where we want to take it now
so there's a lot to be said so first of
all for people who haven't seen it
the interface is exceptionally well done
that's like execution is really
important
here absolutely the other things just to
mention
for a large number of people apparently
which is new to me
don't know what latex is so
it's spelled like latex so be careful
googling it if you haven't before
uh it's uh uh sorry i don't even know
the correct terminology type setting
it's a typesetting language where it's
you're basically program writing a
program that then generates
something that looks from a typography
perspective beautiful
absolutely and so a lot of academics use
it to write papers
i i think there's like a bunch of
communities that use it to write papers
i would say it's mathematics physics
computer science
yeah that's yeah that's the because i'm
collaborating currently on a paper
with two neuroscientists from stanford
and they don't know what
so i'm using uh microsoft word
and uh mendeley and like all of those
kinds of things and it's
and i'm being very zen like about about
the whole process
but it's fascinating it's a little
heartbreaking actually
because um it actually it's it's funny
to say
but uh and we'll talk about open science
actually the bigger mission behind for
mars libraries like
really opening up the world of science
to everybody
is these silly two facts
of like one community uses latex and
another uses
word is actually a barrier
between them that's like it's like
boring and practical in a sense but it
makes it very difficult to collaborate
just on that like i think the if there
are some people that should have
received like a nobel prize that but
we'll never get it and i think one of
those
is like donald knuth because of tech and
tech
then because it had a huge impact in
terms of like just
making it easier for uh researchers to
put their content out there
like making it uniform as much as
possible oh you mean like a
nobel peace prize maybe
maybe a nobel peace prize yeah i
i think so i mean he at a very young age
got the touring award for his work in
algorithms and so on so yeah like an
incredibly
like when i i think it's in it might be
even the 60s but i think it's the 70s
that so when he was really young and
then he went on to do like
incredible work with his book and uh
yeah with tech
that people don't know and going back
just one on the reason why we
we ended up because i think this is
interesting the reason why we ended up
using the name for mars library this was
because of
uh format's last theorem and from us
livestream is actually a funny story
like so pierre de ferma
he was like a lawyer and he
wrote like on a book um that he had a
solution to fermat's last theorem
which but that didn't fit the margin
of that book and so fermat's lasting
basically
states that there's no solution if you
have
integers a b and c there's no solution
to a to the power of n
plus b to the power of n equals to c to
the power of
n if n is bigger than two so there's
there's there's no solutions
and he said that and that problem
remained open for almost 300 years i
believe
and a lot of the most famous
mathematicians tried to tackle that
problem
no one was able to figure that that out
until andrea wiles
uh i think was in in the 90s uh was able
to publish the solution which was i
i believe almost 300 pages long and so
it's kind of an
anecdote that you know there's a lot of
knowledge and insights that can be
trapped
in the margins that you and there's a
lot of potential energy that you can
release
if you actually um spend some time time
trying to digest
that and that was the the origin story
for
for the name yes you can share the
contents of the margins with the world
exactly that could inspire a solution or
a communication that then lease the
solution
but and if you think about papers like
papers are as as
joao was saying probably one of the
densest pieces of text that
any human can read and you have these
researchers like some of the brightest
minds in in these fields
working on like new discoveries and
publishing these work on journals
that are imposing them restrictions in
terms of the number of pages that they
can have
to explain a new scientific breakthrough
so at the end of the day
papers are not optimized for clarity
and for a proper explanation of of that
content because there are so many
restrictions
so there's as i mentioned there's a lot
of potential energy that can be
freed if you actually try to digest a
lot of the contents of
papers can you explain some of the other
things so margins
librarian journal club so journal club
is what a lot of people know us for
uh where we every week we release an
annotated paper
and in all sorts of different fields but
physics yes math
margins is kind of the same software
that we use to to run the journal club
and to
host the annotations but we've made that
available for free
to anybody that wants to use it and so
folks use it at universities and and
for running journal clubs and and so we
just made that freely available
and then librarian is a browser
extension that we developed that is sort
of an
overlay on top of archive so it's about
bringing some of the same
functionality around comments plus
adding some
extra niceties to to archive like being
able to very easily extract
the references of a paper that you're
looking at or being able to extract the
bib deck in order to cite that paper
yourself
so it's an overlay on top of archive the
idea is that you can have that
commenting interface
without having to leave archive it's
kind of incredible i didn't know about
it
and once i've learned of it it's like
holy [ __ ]
why isn't it more popular given how
popular archive is
like everybody should be using it
archive sucks
or uh let me rephrase that it's limited
yeah in terms of
archive is a pretty incredible project
right
and it is in in a way it's it
you know it the growth has been
completely linear
over time if you look at like number of
papers published on archive like you
know it's just been it's pretty much a
straight line for the past 20 years
especially for you know like if you're
coming from a startup background and
then you were trying to do archive
you'd probably try like all sorts of
growth acts and like try to
to then maybe like have paid features
and things like that and
that would kind of maybe ruin it and so
there's
there's a subtle balance there yeah and
i don't know what
what aspects you can change about it
yeah for some
tools in science it just takes time for
them to grow
is just turned 30 i believe yeah and for
for people that don't know archive is
this kind of online repository where
people put
the preprints which are versions of the
papers before they actually make it to
journals
a r a-r-x-i-v exactly for people
who don't know and it's actually a
really vibrant place to publish your
papers in
in the aforementioned uh communities of
mathematics
and computer science it started with
mathematics and physics and then
over the the last 30 years it evolved
and now actually computer
computer science now it's it's a more
popular category than physics and math
on archive and there's also
which i don't know very much about like
a biology medical version of that
bioarchive yeah bioarchive um it's um
it's interesting because if you look at
like these um
platforms for preprints they are they
actually
play a super important role because if
you look at a
category like math for some papers in
math
it might take close to three years
after you click upload paper on the
journal website and the paper gets
published
on the website of the journal so this is
the literally the the longest
upload period on the internet um
and during those three years like it's
it's
you know their content is just you know
locked and so this that's why it's so
important for people to have websites
like
archive so that you can share that
before it goes to the journal
with the rest of the world there was
actually on archive that uh
perumann published the the three papers
that led to the proof of the poincare
conjecture and then you have other
fields like
machine learning for instance where the
the field is evolving at
such a high rate that people don't even
wait before the papers go to journals
before they start working on top of
those papers so they
publish them on archive then other
people see them they start working on
that
and archive did a really good job at
like building that
core platform to host papers but i i
think there's a really really
big opportunity in building more
features on top of that platform
apart from just hosting paper so
collaboration annotations and
like having other things apart from from
papers like code
um and and other things because
for instance in the field like machine
learning there's a really big
you know as i mentioned people start
working on on on top of preprints and
they are assuming that
that that preprint is correct but you
really need a way for instance to
maybe it's not peer review but
distinguish what is good
work from bad work on archive how do you
do that so
like a commenting interface like
librarian it's useful for that so that
you can distinguish that
um at in a field that is growing so fast
as machine learning
and and then you have platforms that
focus for instance on just biology
bioarchive is a good example
bioarchive is also super interesting
because there there's actually
an interesting experiment that was run
in the 60s so in the 60s the
nih um supported this pro this
this experiment called the information
exchange group
which at the time was a way for
researchers to share biology
preprints via mail or using libraries
and that project in the 1960s got
cancelled six years after
it started and it was due to intense
pressure from the journals
to kill that project because they they
were fearing
a com competition uh from from the
pre-prince uh
for in for the journal industry creek
uh was also uh was one of the famous
scientists that opposed
to to the information exchange group
and it's interesting because right now
if you analyze the number of biology
papers
that uh appear first as preprints it's
only two percent of the papers
and it this was almost 50 almost 50
years after that first experiment so you
can see like that
pressure from the journals to cancel
that uh initial version of a pre-print
repo
had a tremendous impact on on on
the number of papers that are showing up
in biology as preprints so it delayed a
lot
that that revolution and um
but now platforms like bioarchive are
doing that work
but there's still a lot of room for
growth there and i think it's super
important because those are the papers
that are open that everyone can read
okay so but if we just look at the
entire process of science as a big
system can we just talk about how
it can be revolutionized so
you have an idea uh depending on the
field
you want to make that idea concrete you
want to run a few experiments in
computer science there might be some
code
there'd be a data set for you know
some of the more sort of biology
psychology
you might be collecting the data set
that's
called you know a study right
so that's part of that that's part of
the methodology
and so you are putting all that into
paper form
and then you have some results
and then you you submit that to a place
for
review through the peer review process
and
there's a process where how would you
summarize the peer review process but
it's it's really just like
a handful of people look over your paper
and comment and based on that decide
whether your paper is good or not so
there's a whole broken nature to it
at the same time i love the peer review
process when i buy stuff on amazon
like uh for like
the commenting system whatever that is
so okay so there's a
bunch of possibilities for revolutions
there and then there's the other side
which is the collaborative aspect of the
science which is people
annotating people commenting sort of the
low effort
collaboration which is a comment
sometimes as you've talked about a
comment can change everything
but you know or a higher effort
collaboration
like more like maybe annotations or even
like contributing to the paper you can
think of like
a collaborative updating of the paper
over time
so there's all these possibilities for
doing
things better than they've been done
can we talk about some ideas in this
space some ideas that you're working on
some ideas that you're not yet working
on but
should be revolutionized because it does
seem
that archive and like open review
for example are like the craigslist
of science like like yeah
okay i'm very grateful that we have it
but it just feels like
it's like 10 to 20 years like it doesn't
feel like that's a feature
the simplicity of it is a feature it
feels like it's a
it's a bug but then again
the the pushback there is wikipedia has
the same kind of
simplicity to it and it seems to work
exceptionally well
in the crowdsourcing aspect of it so
sorry this there's a bunch of stuff
going on
on the table let's just pick random
things that we can talk about
wikipedia you know for me it's the
cosmological constant of the internet
it's i think we are lucky to live in the
parallel universe where wikipedia exists
yes
because if if someone had pitched me
wikipedia like a publicly edited uh
encyclopedia like a couple of years ago
like it would be
i don't know how many people would have
said that that would have survived
i mean it makes almost no sense it's
like having a google doc that everybody
on the internet can edit and like that
will be like the most reliable
source for for knowledge on i don't know
how many
but hundreds of thousands of topics yeah
exactly it's insane it's insane and like
you have
and then you have users like there's one
a single user that
edited one third of the articles on
wikipedia so we have these
really really big power users there are
a substantial part
of like what makes wikipedia successful
and so like no one would have ever
imagined that
that could happen um and so that that's
that's one thing i i completely agree
with what you just said i also
started to interrupt briefly maybe let's
inject that into the discussion of
everything else
i also believe i've seen that with
stackoverflow that one individual
or a small collection of individuals
contribute or
revolutionize most of the community like
if you create a really powerful system
for archive
or like open review and made it really
easy
and uh compelling and exciting
for one person who isn't like a 10x
contributor
to do their thing that's going to change
everything it seems like that was the
mechanism that changed everything for
wikipedia
and that's the mechanism that changed
everything for stack overflow
is gamifying or making it exciting or
just making it fun
or pleasant or fulfilling in some way
for those people who are
insane enough to like answer
thousands of questions or write
thousands of factoids and like research
them and check them all those kinds of
things
or read thousands of papers yeah no
stack overflow is another
great example of that and it's just and
and those are both
to incredibly productive communities
that generate a ton of value
and and and capture almost none of it
right and it's
and you know in a way it's almost like
counter
um it's very counter-intuitive that that
that people that these communities would
exist
and thrive um and and it's really hard
to you you there aren't that many
communities
like that so how do we do that for
science do you have ideas there
like what what are the biggest problems
that you see you're working on some of
them
like just on that there are a couple of
really interesting experiments that
people are running and an example would
be like the polymath projects so this is
a
so kind of a social experiment that was
uh created by tim gower's
field fields medalist and his idea was
to try
to prove that is it possible to do
mathematics in a massively
collaborative collaborative way on the
internet so we
decided to pick a couple of problems and
test that
and they found out that it it actually
it is possible for a specific types of
problems
uh namely problems that you're able to
break down in in little pieces
and go step by step you might need as as
with open source
you might need people that are just kind
of
reorganizing the the house every once in
a while
and then you know people throw a bunch
of ideas and then you know
you make some progress then you
reorganize you reframe the problem you
go step by step
but they were actually able to prove
that it is possible to to
collaborate online and do progress in
terms of mathematics
and so i'm i'm confident that there are
other avenues that could be explored
here
you